[Music]
researchers at the University of
Queensland in Australia say that fish
can be trained to recognize human faces
this is true
that's right fish can recognize human
faces that is just in that crazy story
and yeah it doesn't seem possible no oh
yeah why do you why do you try me this
is odd alright there's a fish in the
audience all right random fish in the
audience well what can we help you what
do you want ok well first of all my name
is mr. gulps mr. gulps alright what
would you like us to do well I'm a pop
culture guy so how about you show me
some celebrity faces and we'll see if I
can recognize them do you think about
that
seems like an incredible waste of time I
still think of over the fact that you
can talk yeah well I think you're just
afraid mr. gulps might make you look bad
I think that's okay here we go mr. gulps
here's your first picture all right take
a look Julia Louie Dreyfus very good
Cate Blanchett oh good
Colin Farrell very good isla Fisher yeah
Topher Grace yeah Joe Pantoliano Anthony
LaPaglia derogate smoothie Kurtz very
nice s epatha merkerson very good Conan
O'Brien okay
oh that
now now
now let's Tilda Swinton Oh [ __ ]
that's you man
wait [ __ ] show this with in common
dammit level [ __ ] get take him away mr.
gulps everybody out of here come on come
on I came here with friends
[Applause]
for mr. bolts there he goes I assure you
mr. Gulch will be escorted out of here
in a humane manner
[Music]
all right take care of all mr. gulps
knob I'm still alive man I'm still
swimming okay I'm down in the singing
yeah flush him again
[Music]
that's gonna do a good bye mr. Goenka
there you go all right
you